overseas a stark reminder that the war
in Syria is far from over
we have an exclusive look at what life
is like for more than 3 million people
trapped in a bombing campaign by Syria
and its ally Russia it Lib is the last
remaining stronghold of opposition
forces in civil in the civil war that
began in 2011 some people are calling
for the u.s. to help stop the siege
Holly Williams got rare access and is
now in Turkey near the Syrian border
Holly what did you see
good morning in Italy yesterday things
were normal which means there were war
planes overhead air strikes and reports
of 16 civilians killed including seven
children there's nowhere left to run for
many in Eid Lib they're impotent against
the faceless killers in the sky our
guides told us this hospital was hit by
an airstrike in the early morning the
regime attacks hospitals like this one
as well as schools markets and bakeries
and for those who survive it makes
things unlivable here and that's the
point this hospital is now the last
resort for around half a million people
the Syrian regime and its Russian
backers are pushing these people to a
breaking point
we found parts of Eid Lib eerily quiet
tens of thousands have fled the town of
maarat al-nouman after it's market was
hit last month
fifty people were massacred by some
reports
[Applause]
but there is no help and so this family
has carved out a makeshift air shelter
underneath their own home their children
take cover here clutching their teddy
bears when the warplanes Menace them
from above and there are new reports
this morning of more airstrikes in it
live including seven people killed
Gayle Paula Williams at video very tough
to watch thank you very much